Captain Nemo and I walked away from the Nautilus in our diving suits.
It was very dark, except for a red light glowing about two miles away.
I saw piles of stones as the red light grew stronger.
Then, I saw a white light on top of a mountain. The red light came from behind it.
I followed Captain Nemo as he began to climb up the mountain,...
...which was covered in dead trees.
I noticed that some of them were pines.
How did they grow here, under the sea?
As we climbed higher, the path became more difficult.
We came to some large caves and I saw giant crabs and lobsters in them.
I wanted to stop and study them,...
...but Captain Nemo continued to climb, and I had to follow him.
We came to a wide flat area where I saw the ruins of buildings covered in seaweed.
Still the captain did not stop, and we climbed to the top of the mountain.
It was a volcano.
The red light came from lava flowing down the other side of the mountain.
Below it, I could see an entirely ruined city.
Captain Nemo took a piece of white rock and scratched a word on a black rock: Atlantis.
This was the ancient city that the Greek historians wrote about.
It had been destroyed by earthquakes and sunk below the sea.